well previous board trustees are
reacting to the news of the
superintendent being ousted joe moeller
continues our team coverage with more
joe and the trustees we spoke to say
they are heartbroken over what has
unfolded and are worrying about the
students and educators now
we caught up with former trustee terry
janison earlier today she spent five
years as a school board trustee she
thinks dr jarrah has done a decent job
considering the circumstances she has
been watching the turmoil and is
saddened that the trustees and
superintendent couldn't work together
what i've been seeing
is just really
sad for
number one our children
but number two our community i just
believe that the behavior of the school
board specifically has been so
disappointing
and i just think it reflects badly on
the entire clark county she is worried
there won't be a superintendent that
will want to come work for the district
she hopes the trustees and the district
can overcome this i hope they all figure
out what their jobs are as trustees and
then what their jobs are as officers
because it's very specific
we also spoke to sheila moulton who was
a trustee for 12 years we'll have much
more on what she has to say coming up
here at five reporting the studio joe
muller live local now thank you joe
the fda has authorized a smaller dose of
pfizer's coven 19 vaccine for children
between the ages of 5 and 11. it's a
critical step for the more than 28
million children that may soon be
eligible next week advisors for the cdc
will meet to make their own
recommendation
and if the cdc director agrees then
shots could be available the following
day
nevada health response has not yet
updated the covid dashboard latest
numbers show 108 cases per 100 000
people here in clark county our test
positivity rate sitting at about 6
percent just more than 55 percent of
clark county residents are fully
vaccinated christian
well trick-or-treating is back but
health experts still want families to be
coveted conscious here are some simple
precautions from doctors to have fun but
a safe halloween
six-year-old talia chang can't wait for
halloween lots of skittles and
chocolates but she knows her peacock
costume will have a very important
accessory our daughter will still wear a
mask
when she's trick-or-treating and we will
as well health officials say it's safe
for children to enjoy halloween this
year if simple covet precautions are in
place dr mercedes karnathon with
northwestern medicine says everyone
should mask up especially if you welcome
trick-or-treaters at the door there's no
way to predict the density of children
who are going to come together and
there's no way to know
which households they're approaching
whether or not